[Music]
take it a little bit higher good
alright I'm gonna give you a serve
really spinny serf already it's gonna go
that way okay all right now your serve
let's see here we go
oh right off the belly that's the one
okay there you go you're catching it now
look at that that's sweet
excellent come on you're gonna score
you're gonna score here one of these
times there it is come on all right
that's good yeah you would see I would
say I'd have to play your backhand oh
there you go you got it you got it
ah there you go ah whoops nice obviously
new back look at that all right we need
you to score again here we go
I both disappeared on you now I'm gonna
give it a spin it's gonna shoot that way
so yeah you're gonna have to try to stop
it from going over there it got me I I
could serve forehand nice I mean you're
not even breaking the sweat I'm over
here needed out I got a little sweat you
got me moving that's for sure it's nice
and warm this morning with the chasing
balls yeah you get you're gonna bring
back the grip I'm gonna bring back the
grip the unique similar grip and I'm
gonna do my best and whatever that is
that's good enough for me